couldn't we just smash Jupiter into the
Sun that sounds like more fun to
me well this would make for some good
fireworks but this would increase the
Sun's mass too quickly causing it to
burn hot enough to turn global warming
into Global roasting even if we managed
to nudge Jupiter close enough to the Sun
that could lead to a whole slew of other
problems because without Jupiter's
stable gravitational pull all of our
planetary orbits including Earth's would
be thrown off course and we'd lose our
precious Shield against deadly asteroids
and
comets so realistically we'd probably
have to suck it up and move somewhere
else who knows maybe there's a really
nice earthlike exoplanet out there for
us to settle